welcome everyone today is a thesis
proposal defense by one of our students
Andrew when and Andrew is a master
student in the was now called health and
clinical informatics track he's also in
the OHSU PSU 3+2 programs so he's
simultaneously getting bachelor's degree
in computer science at Portland State
he's interested in natural language
processing yes are his committee members
the two Stevens and myself and also
performance optimization of software
applications so he's mostly been working
with his primary advisor dr. Wu on NLP
based layered language implementation of
clinical text search which is funded by
a grant from the National Library of
Medicine so he will give a presentation
defending his proposal and then we can
ask questions of him and if the
committee's satisfied he can then move
on to the next step which is performing
his master's thesis yes one other number
oh okay
oh I'm sorry okay
great okay well okay there's more
committee members including dr. Todd
then a great amount of effort being made
towards storing medical records in
electronic form this has unlocked the
possibility for computational processing
of these medical records applications
which range from such things as research
for instance corporate identification
big data to practical applications such
as clinical decision support but in
order to do these things software must
first be able to derive meaning from
text itself because if you just pass it
a raw raw text unstructured text it
doesn't understand it's just a string of
characters but we can't understand that
so the field of research attempting to
solve this problem is natural language
processing where we attempt to generate
semantic structures from text and
recently there's been efforts being made
towards implementing natural language
processing for the clinical domain so
tailoring naturally is passing to be
able to extract clinical information
there's been great progress made in this
but there are still several items and
clinical types that aren't extracted and
we seek to fill one of these holes so
the purpose of this project is to
extract lab values from a clinical
document if we are given knowledge that
a lab test exists so if we know that
like that test was done and that it is
present in the clinical text we want to
extract the lab value associated with it
and so the question we derived from this
is whether SEM and Robles approaches the
way to two approaches to the problems
that have been discussed in relation to
extraction research whether they are
applicable to a lot value extraction and
can be done so with similar results and
for template performance and you may ask
why we would be interested in extracting
lab result values one potential
application is it's very useful for
research
one of the biggest bottlenecks in terms
of research time is cohort
identification where you want to
identify a set of applications that are
applicable to what you want to research
so having lab values with the useful
because you would be able to search for
it
set up patients with a certain certain
set of lab values and you can then I
don't actually use that to search and
generate a cohort to perform a research
on rather than having to manually go
through an entire patient database and
pick out the ones that are applicable to
you secondarily it's also useful for
Studies on Texas through the entity so
you could for instance look for a set of
patients with an abnormal test results
and then compared to whether or not they
actually had whether or not they
actually had words diagnosed with the
condition that a test was supposed to
look for and from that you can determine
how good the test actually is in a
practice context and finally a third use
would be pick the analysis where for
instance you could look for a set of
patients that were diagnosed with
certain conditions and you could then
analyze their lab results try and
identify outliers and I wrap I've
learned abnormalities sorry here beyond
just research applications they are also
used this would also be useful for
practical applications so for instance
automatic clinical decision support
right now the uses structured dist
structured lab values that were manually
input to help support clinician
decisions but for instance indicates of
unstructured text so I'm check the
records that were converted from paper
usually this is just ocr'd and wrote X
so the CGS system cannot understand and
as such it doesn't use those past lab
values unless it has been manually
converted and input into the software so
being able to autonomously extract this
information would actually reduce a
great deal of overhead which as a more
general thing that this would also
increase backwards compatibility with
older text records because one of the
greatest overheads to conversion to semi
structured electronic health records is
actually filling out those structures
with data and oftentimes you will have
to manually go through records and input
them and being able to autonomously fill
more of them with great
the overhead of the conversion task so
for this project we plan on using
building up of two primary other works
for one we don't plan on implementing a
natural language processing engine from
scratch take part too much time and
quite frankly I don't have the expertise
to do so instead we will be using their
chemical text analysis and exacting
system which is an open source natural
language processing engine that was
specifically tailored to extract
components that are relevant to the
clinical domain and we plan on using
these components that they extract to
support our implementation of a lot
value extractor quite important to note
that as of right now C takes does not
have the ability to extract lab values
pairs and I result level okay so being
able to add this support would be a
useful contribution to the community in
general for our record site that we plan
on performing NLP on we will be using
the itv2 datasets so I do teach ITP to
host a yearly national language passing
challenge that challenges people to
extract certain semantic features from
clinical text the specifics automatic
features differ from year to year but
the most important point is at the end
of the task they release generated data
set with all the annotations that they
were looking for over that challenge
input and present and for our purposes
of particular uses of 2010 ITP to
challenge because it contains
information on lab tests part of its
concepts and Relations identification
challenge and you'll know earlier the
problem I presented was if we are told
that there is a certain set of lab
results we want to extract the values
are associated with them so this is the
disease that would actually give us the
lab results that we want to be given
first in order to extract developments
at least as far as implementation goes
the task we are facing is twofold first
device performance named entity
recognition on the
on to extract my values and then we must
relate them back to the lab result
annotation itself so name and he
recognition there's multiple approaches
that have been discussed in literature
several of which include dictionary
lookup rule-based approaches and machine
learning approaches a prior study done
on a lot value extraction in slightly
different circumstances by Kong Adel
suggests that row based approaches might
perform the pet for life value
extraction specifically so we will be
using an Abbott adaptation of this to in
our own life value namely recognition
for relational extraction there's also
several different approaches again
rule-based ambriel patterns unsupervised
learning supervised learning which is
what we plan on doing in our project so
for implementation there will be three
phases first we plan on manually
creating a gold standard so we have a
manual annotation phase where we go
through the 2010 data set and manually
annotate the correct values and the
relation logic that associate supply
value with the lab results application
and kind of implementing this as a DX
component to iterate through the data
sets and queries the users for the
correct input if it is present and once
we have created this goal Center we can
use it for evaluation purposes later on
your project after this phase we plan on
doing a automated extraction which is
the bulk of a project so we want to do
the first the same same task as the
first manual adhesion component but we
want it to be done autonomously and so
again the task is twofold first we want
to extract all the possible lab values
within a document so we want to identify
and create annotations for what we
believe are lab values and then we want
to relate them back to the we want to
determine whether extracted value is
actually related to a different lab
result and I'll provide my examples of
this later on in this presentation and
finally we want to perform at valuation
where we compare our exact annotations
with the granular could it goes down to
a battery precision recall and in that
one story so as a general overview of
what the task we need to do is so let's
say we had a segment of text that's
another hematocrit level of thirty five
percent we are given as highlighted in
blue here a lot of annotation that says
this is a malakut but not test that has
Yama's test unique identifier type unity
unique identifier of p34 which is
laboratory procedure and test results
and what we seek to do is identify the
items highlighted in green here so first
we want to extract the 35% want to
identify that this is a lot value that
has a value of 35 and a unit of percent
and then we want to associate it back to
the lab annotation itself so the first
text task we do is then to extract all
these lab values present in the text so
for this example segment here on
patients on the 15th of January who had
a hemoglobin hematocrit of 16 grams with
double year and 35 percent respectively
our task is twofold first we want to
extract extract all the correct values
of 16 grams per deciliter and the 5% but
we don't want to extract other unrelated
numerical values such as 15 of January
which isn't lab like Valley and post we
are planning on take taking here this is
a row based approach so we anticipate
during the manual annotation page we
will notice several prevalence patterns
in terms of how how lab tests are
written and their respective results and
this may differ depending on a specific
section of text so for instance of lab
lab results written inside the personal
medical history world differs
significantly it would be more narrative
style as opposed to versus observation
which would be more bullet point this is
the test this is the result for instance
so the pattern we may use for baited
differ depending on this specific
specific section of text
and then other factors that we plan on
using include the presence of a numeric
value in help itself the presence of a
unit of measure which is actually finite
although very LifeSite and the distance
between a numerical value and the units
of measure so if for instance a
prospective numeric value and the unit
of measure is ten words or parts very
likely not an actual value right and the
distance between the prospectively
closest lab result annotation and the
what we believe may be a lab value if
they're very far apart again it's highly
unlikely that this is a lie value okay
so once this is done we have a set of
lab values but then we must then relate
them back to the lab results in of
themselves so for instance in that
previous tech segment I showed you we
had two labs done we had the Connecticut
and hemoglobin but we don't know which
one of the two 16 grams per deciliter
and 35 percent is associated with which
that is our next task is we must
determine whether each pairing of value
in lab is actually whether or not
they're actually related to each other
and to accomplish this we will be using
supervised learning we'll be using an
approach called the support vector
machine which is essentially a
classifier that determines whether each
possible pair of lab result and lab
values is within a given document is
actually related to each other
and we'll be using various features to
support the support vector machine that
is given to us through C takes such as
parts of speech determining tokens the
distance between the two the umls
concept IDs for the lab results the
dependency tree and take sections and
weren't in writing so once this was done
we must then perform evaluation
determining how well our automated
extraction performed so support vector
machines are supervised learning
approach so what that means is they must
be spread test data first in order to
actually be able to perform our training
data personally I should be able to
perform well so to accomplish this we
plan on using leave one out cross
validation what that means is when we
are evaluating a doctor
on an annotated document we plan on
using there were many documents within
the record set to train to train the SEM
on the gun standard and one-sided that
is done we perform evaluation so for
purposes of this study we define a hit
positive hit as a numeric value that is
correctly associated with the relevant
laboratory annotation most importantly
we allow for some discrepancy and unit
identification so we use units to help
support our our lab value name and he
recognition but it is not the goal of
this study to build a comprehensive unit
dictionary so so we allow for some
discrepancies there and once that is
done we just compare our generate
results against the gold standard using
the definition for hit as outlined above
to evaluate true positives false
positives false negatives and then we
can from there determine precision
recall at one score and several
limitations in this project for one
named entity recognition of lab results
is outside the scope of this project so
we only seek to define by values exact
values and the relation back to lab
results but in a practical context lab
results much extracted as well because a
lot value and of itself 35% doesn't mean
anything unless it's associated with
hematocrit lab for instance what that
means is in a practical application we
can only ever perform as well as the lab
result annotator
so even if we get perfect extracted from
ours which is for one highly unlikely
but even then if our if the lab results
annotation is only performs that like 60
percent then overall the entire workflow
will always perform education person so
we're constrained by that split second
major limitation is in terms of the data
structure we use for sewing lab results
so you'll note that we only identify
numeric values but beyond that songs lab
has special representations for instance
probably a very common one is blood
pressure for instance
has two numeric values and they're all
relevant and it cannot be represented
well in the data structure we use
because for instance there's no unit
associated with it I mean there is that
you could start written and beyond that
we also have comparative statements
which are not supported so for instance
if someone would use a hematocrit level
of less than 35% our extractor would
associate 35% with hematocrit but it
would not it would not grab the lesson
part so it would just say hematocrit is
35% we entered States being able to
contribute several things to active
research community in general the person
which would be the annotation and Healey
datasets that we produce during the
manual annotation phase so this would
have all the lab values and relations to
the lab results included within the data
set and secondly we plan on producing a
CD X component capable of performing
this value extracting the Association
autonomously which we plan on eventually
releasing on to github to for
contribution back to open source
community we don't know how well this
will perform yet ideally we wanted to
perform well so for that we defined this
as f1 score of greater than point six
five which is a score selected due to it
being similar to the performance on
others similar relation extracting tax
and for future expenses of this work
applicability before we constrained by
extended namely entity recognition for
lab results so expanding performance of
this improving it will also improve the
performance of our our task in the
overall workflow in practical
applications furthermore it is important
to note that the SEM and rule-based
approach is one of many possible
approaches to lavallee extraction and
this is one that we selected both due to
personal preference and because of
studies that suggest that this may be
the best approach to take what we don't
know that for sure
it may be
better alternative approach Mary perform
better it might be worthwhile
investigation and finally extensions on
supported live without tax and there was
representation for instance being able
to support the bill special lab results
as much as before as well as comparative
statements and with that I thank you for
your time any questions so we have a
interesting work and important on it
might be beyond the scope but what about
time because you did your taking time
into account because it's different if a
medical record says you know five years
ago mr. Jones had a hematocrit of twenty
six versus you know saying you know he
came into the clinic today and we
ordered it tested adequate was 26
the this project isn't it and of itself
would not actually do that it would be a
useful future future expansion but right
now we're only interested in extracting
a lot value and associated back to the
lab results which I mean that would
still be that would still be applicable
here you just want to add an additional
annotation that says this was several
years ago as opposed to this was just
laughing just because you know sometimes
values change you know like if I had an
acute bleeding episode you know he you
know he was in the hospital recently in
his Matic crit you know had a big bleed
his manic rate fell down to 20 you know
and then when he was transfused and he
got better and here is back in the
clinic and it's 36 so [ __ ] chiming
that sort of temporal relationship thing
is like a huge ongoing medical NLP thing
and one night this project is the data
set that he's going to produce would be
really good starting point and to be
from his annotations are exactly the
ones that you would want either do would
depend on as part of any kind of temple
militia quantifiers so that's like a
really nice logical extension
okay you give the example of some
special circumstances the missile host
seemed kind of important there a way to
like basically like vital signs right so
any context of the data structures I
plan to implement there you can you can
write special case rules that extract
them into a certain format for instance
blood pressure it would just have a
special rule that says this is what my
pressure looks like the first number
like an average falling slowly can you
would implement that as two separate lab
values that with that both be related
back to the lab is not result a
patient's a future extension of this
work again would be possibly to write a
more abstract set of representation that
would be able to support all these
different special cases out of the box
because right now again you have to
write special case rules to actually add
support for these and maybe you said
earlier either there are certain types
of lab values that you're focusing on
you gave the example of somatic R is
that I mean is there a certain group of
lab values that are particularly
important we stick to the things we
think to be a general lab Ally expected
but right now a limitation would be as
we have we are only expecting numeric
values with units
I'm not complaining for the record what
is your timeline for your project that
is for discussion
I think I I've already done a good
portion of the work related to this so I
think it could be a bit faster than
expected but I'm aiming for two months
or so maybe which might seem Clara
accelerated but again I've done a good
portion it's like ready so nice
presentation one suggestion I have when
you get to your write-up
I would go ahead and put the equations
in for ya everything definitions so
anytime you use SVM rightly I think we
can all figure out what you're doing
from Lisa's top oh you're at some point
going to be writing up a progress report
so it would just be really careful to
define everything and put in all the
equations easier to see zero yeah I have
that problem all the time so it's good
to be reminded
so you mentioned about we talked a
little bit in your pre meeting but a
little more about what you plan to do
with the results so the process would be
twofold so first we will want to release
the source on github for evaluation and
then after that we will want to submit a
polar Skua request to the main civics
project in the app itself for inclusion
into the aesthetics project as a its own
component assuming we get adequate
performance so performance that isn't
terrible for instance though we want
that want to ask you take to include our
component back in the project so that it
gets distributed automatically everyone
that you see takes
to an extent so evaluation would be we
perform our own evaluation to determine
performance but people would then
evaluate when they when we submit a pull
request to see basically would then want
to determine for themselves whether or
not it's worth viable for inclusion
because or instance I mean I can just go
up to them and say hey I have this thing
that performance 99% of the time right
but I mean no one's going to trust that
do it's going to want to cross over five
in this outflow it makes it get up is
really more of a repository it's not
like application that's sitting there
running so people can go to github it
has a whole built-in workflow for but
it's like what it does that's like hey I
made this Bank it's like vegetables
project we don't care about that
projects kind of a list of notifications
that they pay attention to and when you
you know issue a pull request what
you're doing the same two people are in
a project I have got to stop for you and
it is really easy that's kind of fill it
to write back and say hey thanks that's
great but fix this
some sort of china understand sort of a
flow of dissemination thank you that but
I'm just trying to figure out how you
the flow of dissemination seaside the
project so would you sort of publish it
somehow
before what so ideally I think the
process that would we would first
publish what our method was for
implementation and then our results and
then we will also publish its source
alongside it and then when we submit the
poll requests to see takes so what we
ask them to includes our component
inside their a project we would then
include the information that we
published about the methods and scoring
and then they could evaluate for
themselves or not what we said was that
who true perhaps perhaps
I mean anyone can publish you get like I
don't have it like I don't have it but
my stuff is always like you know even
before I publish anything but there's
Under
so one more question so you mentioned
that you were looking for a certain
level of accuracy did you say what which
you looking for so I'm looking for an f1
score which is a combined metric that
combines precision and recall it into
I'm looking for 10.65 or above but
obviously higher is better but we're
somewhere relation extracting tasks the
performance beauty hovers around there
so what's what we thought good I did see
that points are surprised by that so
that's here so if you hit that then
you're done well I mean obviously we
want higher better performers like it it
would be stellar if it's like 0.99 for
instance but but that's not always
possible like where a lot of published
papers it's quite exciting for relation
a second so that I mean I've been doing
that as a baseline board this is what we
get acceptable results for right
performance that's on par with others
Auto relation exact attack
thank you